three-two-one yeah ignition
blasting into the sky from the same
historic launch pad where astronauts
first set off to the moon this moment
may turn out to be no less significant
crowds who'd waited patiently in the
darkness were witnessing a giant leap
forward the future of commercial space
travel on top of a full Canaan rocket
SpaceX's crewed dragon coming up at 2
minutes and 35 seconds testing the first
ever private spaceship built to carry
astronauts proved a nerve-wracking night
for the entrepreneur behind the mission
tree Frank I'm I'm a little emotionally
exhausted because I was super stressful
but it worked so far we have to dock the
station or to come back but as far as
worked for the one passenger on board it
was a lonely launch but Ripley the dummy
named after the alien films had a job to
do fitted with sensors around her head
neck and spine the data she gathers will
show whether or not the spacecraft is
ready to carry humans remembers the
public though the real fun thing would
be seeing sliced a little celestial
buddy a little tiny Earth humanoid earth
thing floating around in zero g the
rocket will reach the International
Space Station on Sunday just 27 hours
after leaving it'll deliver 400 pounds
of supplies and deliveries for the
existing team up there after spending
five days docked at the space station on
Friday it'll return landing back in the
Atlantic since NASA ended its own space
shuttle in 2011 its relied on Russia to
get astronauts to the International
Space Station paying for the privilege
at 61 million pounds of seat it's a test
flight but not really for us we we
consider this one four score it really
is flying to the ISS and we really want
to protect the crew onboard and the
assets
SpaceX isn't the only commercial company
that wants in on the action Boeing's
Starliner will carry out its own test
flight in April for NASA contracting out
crew transport should make space
exploration more affordable in the next
couple of decades it hopes to go back to
the moon and to Mars this might only be
a test run for SpaceX but the pressure
is on if successful the trial carrying
real passengers could happen as soon as
this summer
Casey Spencer Sky News